mais merci d'abord je voudrais dire un
gros merci à celle qui m'a accompagné
tout le long de cette campagne hollande
mon amour et puis mes enfants amélie
alexis milette conjointe d'alexis qui
ont été là aussi on se parlait que les
jo et puis merci de me plier comme vous
le faites actuellement je veux remercier
toutes celles et tous ceux qui ont voté
pour moi dans laurier sainte marie
toute l'équipe de la campagne celles
d'autobus sel dans le conté cellou
nationale j'en profite pour féliciter
hélène laverdière qui a remporté cette
élection dans laurier sainte marie
oh là là là c'est la démocratie il faut
respecter ça c'est bien sûr que les
résultats ne sont pas exactement ce que
nous avons souhaité mais on a mené
véritablement une belle campagne
on ne croyait presque disparu mais nous
voilà plus présent que l'on était non
nous sommes nous sommes arrivés peu à
court de notre objectif et nous partions
de loin de très loin et nous avons
progressé
les québécoises et des québécois ont
voté pour nous par centaines de milliers
je les en remercie
cette belle campagne nous devons
beaucoup à nos militants nos militants
vous étiez au rendez vous partout dans
toutes les régions enthousiaste et fier
merci merci infiniment
les candidates et les candidats du bloc
québécois ont fait campagne
vigoureusement dignement jusqu'au bout
vous pouvez être fiers de vous et puis
on monte donc sur scène les élus
félicite résolus la banque et non me
rejoignent dans ma joie
les élus les candidats seulement on
était tous dedans même équipe
je sais que
je sais qu'il y en a d'autres qui s'en
vient et nous rejoindra donc je tiens
également su a salué toutes les
candidates tous les candidats de chacun
des partis je félicite justin trudeau
pour sa victoire bien méritée je pense
qu'il a travaillé fort il a remonté
toute une côte faut le féliciter
je salue également et je vais parler je
salue également six venant masquer le
coeur et le sous-vêtement dans cette
campagne
le bloc pu compter sur les militants les
députés la direction du parti québécois
et son chef pierre karl péladeau et je
remercie
on a pu compter sur les militantes et
militants la direction d'option
nationale et son chef seul l'aîné tiges
dire merci et on a plus compte également
sur des militants et militantes de
québec solidaire des militants des
militants oui oui oui oui quand dans la
rivière du loup était de québec
solidaire
avez vous rendez vous sur rené saisies
étaient nous avons accompli le début de
quelque chose la convergence de beaucoup
de militants militantes des forces
souverainistes
le québec doit prendre sa place partout
tout le temps
pâton que les autres bonnes nouvelles
moi je passe moi je pense qu'il vaut
mieux être un pays dans l'ombre d'une
province dans le canada
mais tant que ça durera nous devons nous
pour nous tenir debout pour défendre nos
intérêts remous voir nos valeurs
protéger nos droits
et cela en tout respect du canada des
canadiennes et des canadiens et surtout
en tout respect de nous mêmes nous avons
affiché clairement et fièrement nos
convictions dans nos coeurs et dans nos
tripes dans nos têtes
le québec est notre seul pays si ce que
mon père nous disait il ya 25 ans je
vous le dis à mon tour et en particulier
à toute cette relève tous ces jeunes qui
ont investi le bloc québécois
je suis revenu aussi pour vous les
jeunes vous êtes beau à voir aller et je
compte sur vous pour la suite
je termine par ces quelques mots aux
milliers de personnes que j'ai
rencontrées tout au long de cette longue
campagne doivent saint-pierre à
ville-marie au témiscamingue de roberval
à gaspé jusqu'à cette île de québec à
sherbrooke et de trois-rivières à
longueuil de mascouche berthier joliette
saint-hyacinthe jusqu'à morial l'accueil
que vous m'avez réservé et à québec où
si on me dit vernon zahoui à québec
comme si on était cinq cents personnes
samedi soir à québec d'accueil que vous
m'avez réservé partout m'a fait vraiment
chaud au coeur le québec que j'aime
c'est vous bonne fin de soirée